I do what I do because of my dad she  gave his life through the pursuit of  knowledge  because up there is where our stories  can be told  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  this is a top-secret psychological  evaluation please describe your current  emotional state I'm steady I'm ready to  do my job to the best of my abilities  [Music]  I will remain calm  I will remain focused  I look just like your dad there he was  the first man to the outer solar system  he was a pioneer  but there was much more to him than man  [Music]  please state your mission objective I am  attempting to stop uncontrolled  antimatter reacts that's strange I  entire solar system we're approaching  Mars  [Music]  space con believes my father's  responsible  we're doing big things up here real big  [Music]  what did he find out there in the abyss  the enemy up here  is not a person or a thing  it's the endless void  the world awaits our discovery my son  you  [Music]  you